hey welcome to another let's play video
in which I'm going to redo my paths
because basically you might have seen in
the last couple of episodes that i had
like for some reason i had copies of
multiple sets in my style theme so i
decided to go into my style themed and
actually look for the sets that I had
like multiple versions of and it turned
out I had a whole lot of sets that i
clear three times within my father so I
went ahead and deleted some of those
things but for some reason that also
means that and because I was a complete
idiot and I used the versions that I
deleted that I lost loads of stuff and
one of those things that actually lost
what's that path set so that's kind of
why all of the beings all of their
little paths and other things that I've
done with that set and how I've even
done the roofs with that set for some
reason I kind of lost all of that so you
might notice that I still need to kind
of fix that but that was why I did that
at the beginning of the video but anyway
today's the day when I'm going to do
something extraordinary and a lot wow
that was extraordinary um yeah because
I'm working on the wing rider a well and
the main reason for that is peer
pressure I don't know many people told
me hey why aren't you working on the
wing line and I was like [ __ ] the ring
wing ride anyway I don't want to work on
that thing but now so many people asked
it that I was like no why not so yeah
that hands why I'm kind of building this
path over here and of course grid
texturing because that is very important
very important you must never forget to
use the grid to make your textures
because it's sexy it's very sexy which
is something that I say too often about
custom scenario and game related things
for some reason especially as of lately
but yeah and you might notice that i'm
also using the kind of well checkerboard
pattern on the path but it's not really
a checkerboard pattern it's kind of
different it's kind of like getting one
texture and then just bringing another
texture here in there but not everywhere
it's like a checkerboard pattern where
one of the textures doesn't quite appear
as often as the other one and actually
works out quite nice because it means
that I have that nice oily texture
of the well soil really and also that
kind of lightness of the sand but yeah
anyway I started working on the queue
and I have no clue what this is really
about I just decided to do it on a whim
and I decided I'm going to have a wooden
walkway so I built a wooden walkway and
that's pretty much how this happened
though I don't think this is really the
best q I find that it's actually more
fun to build things we kind of need to
build around for exam with things and
what I mean with that is when you're
kind of limited and what you need to do
it sort of works as a guideline to kind
of overcome your limitations so I
decided okay I'm going to build a stupid
ugly path as a queue and then see what I
can themed around that as a kind of a
starting point and that's why I kind of
got the ideas to make a kind of spooky
scary skeleton castle kind of thing with
steampunk because this is steampunk pike
and alpine and of course some spooky
manor influences so I have no clue where
this is going to be like but that's what
we'll see i guess so i took as a kind of
starting point because i didn't feel
like really doing the station so I was
definitely procrastinating that at this
moment I decided to do this little
tunnel kind of thing which I'm going to
add some nice little towers to and other
things but first of all I had to decide
on the support colors because I didn't
really know what kind of color scheme I
really wanted to use of course I made
the trek orange which is an interesting
choice I suppose it's not really that
common especially not for this theme so
I didn't really exactly know what to do
with this with the colors for the
supports so decided to go with green but
then I was like me so I went with purple
and um oh ok that's kind of just how I
feel but this color scheme it's just um
mmm okay it's cooler I I guess I'll just
see what it looks like eventually
because they've been a number of times
where i built a coaster i went with a
color scheme and then after I place all
the scenery decided that the color
scheme didn't fit the scenery that's
just something that happens sometimes
and something you have to just go with I
guess but
with this I decided to add towers
because me you know me and my towers
towers are awesome and of course a
little arc kind of thing don't really
know how that works don't really know
what kind of structure this is even
supposed to be but hey it looks cool I
guess so that's that now this is a very
weird kind of mix of tech and well not
yeah textures of course because they're
mixing very weird sets that i'm not
actually really used in mixing how I'm
not even used to using many of these
sets it's kind of a mix of the medieval
of station jim's castle things then
there is also station jim's house that
what's that sack hold again like this is
a spooky I didn't even know it anymore
the ghost cabin set I think yeah that I
use for that and then there's also the
underground kind of thing and fines and
weird stuff and alpine village by shy
guy so that's kind of a weird mix mm-hmm
but yeah the idea behind this were staff
kind of a gate over here with some
towers on top of it kind of a cliché I
know and also intimate with castles and
all that is also somewhat of a cliche
kind of thing that many people have done
before so I decided to go and kind of do
it in a slightly different way and add
some spooky elements elements to that
but in the end it's still an intimate
with a castle and it's still kind of
kind of like a cliche kind of thing hmm
and so yeah and oh god oh god the
windows I just couldn't I just couldn't
settle on any windows because they would
either look ugly like honestly some of
the windows just sucked or they would
have a terrible render distance or I
couldn't use them for other reasons or
they didn't even fit the walls so I've
been messing with many windows in this
episode and that was kind of a kind of a
weird thing I I guess it's not too bad
in the end I mean 0 geez windows do look
pretty cool but I've already used them
in numerous places in the park so I
would have liked to use other windows
but hey I guess that comma didn't want
that was something so then I decided to
do that and then I decided to not do
that because terraforming is annoying
who really
the only reason why I didn't go with a
terraformed kind of walkway is the fact
that terraforming is annoying and
because the game is stupid so they have
that I was just too lazy to work around
with the stupid mechanics of this game
sometimes okay got me some slack I
sometimes I don't even want to work with
this and sometimes I just feel like I'm
going to build such epic things in rolla
co second three and then I opened the
game and then I build things and I'm
like [ __ ] you Rocco second three you're
so annoying and then I close the game
that actually happens but yeah I decided
to just kind of not do that today oh by
the way the reason I keep like making
those stupid noises is because that was
just cinta class over here it's the
sixth of December and we still have
loads of candies left so I ate all of it
and now I don't really feel good that
was that that was actually the best
timing of a voice crack ever oh gosh but
yeah now you might be looking at the
station and be like what are you doing
you just keep doing random things and
yes I don't I don't even actually have a
plan with this station either I just
decided to build random things random
shapes and just kind of get and it's
random as possible station now there is
a huge risk in this because of course if
you kind of build it random it might
just turn out to be something bad but
then again I kind of want something
that's somewhat unique I don't want to
do I don't want to rehash things that
other things other people have already
done numerous times and I kind of want
to do something that I've never done
either I like to get out of my comfort
zone but yeah and that's why I'm just
building random things really the only
problem that I have with this is of
course that i'm still using alpine roofs
because they're good oh that was another
weird kind of thing it's the fact that i
actually use that romana Asmodeus set
for many of the walls and other things
and it's pretty funny because it's a
Roman SAT but it actually kind of mix in
with the others that's some reason so I
just decided to go with it so might as
well but yeah that's it for this episode
so thank you so much for watching and
alpha
[ __ ] off in the next episode bye